il ya bien des gens qui pensent que les
clandestins
les sans-papiers profitent des mêmes
services que nous ce sont ce statut on
se sent comme un sous homme
on se sent comme sous citoyens depuis la
coved 19
certains d'entre eux se retrouvent dans
des conditions extrêmement précaires
cette hausse invitait
ensuite on a commencé à contaminer tout
le village
exploitée par des arnaqueurs je me suis
retrouvé dans une toile de mensonges et
fausses promesses
ils ont peur de tomber malade de se
blesser dans les métiers qui pratique
qui sont parfois extrêmement dangereux
mais surtout ils ont peur d'être
renvoyés dans leur pays parce qu'ils
savent qu'il ya un risque de détention
qui est un risque de déportation alors
qu'ils se rendent au travail alors
qu'ils amènent leurs enfants à l'école
on va vous révéler comment ça se passe
dans ce que le gouvernement appelle les
centres de surveillance pour les
clandestins mais qui vraiment
ressemblent davantage à des prisons ici
marie maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
ils sont partout vous les croisez dans
la rue et dans les transports en commun
et sont vos amis et vos collègues de
travail et construisons maison d'un
immeuble et nos routes
ils produisent notre nourriture et qu
ils contribuent à l'essor économique du
pays
mais souvent ils occupent des emplois
difficiles qui n'intéressent pas les
autres travailleurs ce que je fais c'est
vraiment pour la survie parce que je
n'ai pas le choix
c'est humiliant c'est rabaissant c'est
frustrant si ils se cachent
parce qu'ils sont recherchés par les
autorités le risque de se retrouver dans
les mailles de l'agencé havas
frontaliers ça passe par les policiers
dans la majorité des cas ça passe par
les policiers et donc les gens ont peur
leur crime travail au noir sans papiers
et vivre ici de manière irrégulière
clandestinement ça peut être un
cauchemar de ville dans la clandestinité
on vit dans la peur constante de se
faire renvoyer dans un de nos pays
ils se font normalement discret même si
certains sont ici depuis plus d'une
décennie
mais la coved les a poussés à sortir de
l'ombre
[Musique]
un nombre important de sans papiers ont
pris la rue pour réclamer le droit de
vivre ici du jamais vu au canada à cause
de pandémie ils ont perdu leur emploi
comme beaucoup de canadiens mais ils
n'ont pas des d'économique in en toi
rien qu'on avait plus d'argent pour
payer le loyer ni pour manger ils
seraient des dizaines voire des
centaines de milliers au canada oui à
des gens qui peuvent jouer le système le
direct la vaste majorité c'est des
drames humains
et pourtant il n'existe pas pour les
gouvernements ils sont ignorés de tous
pour une rare fois ils racontent leur
histoire et certains montrent même leur
visage
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ces
gens de ces invisibles
[Musique]
ce jeune homme est l'un des porte parole
des sans papiers au canada il s'appelle
abdul ils luttent pour que des milliers
de personnes sortent de la clandestinité
ce sens ce statut on se sent comme un
sous homme en ce sens comme citoyen on
vit au jour le jour si si vraiment la
solitude complet
des gens qui se cachent y vivent
pratiquement deux heures chaque jour
il s'est transformé en lieder un peu
malgré lui
c'est un homme timide mais déterminée
mais pas vivre dans la justice
je peux pas supporter l'injustice et
c'est ça me remonte les jours d'abdul au
canada sont comptés il est visé par un
mandat de déportation et jusqu'à tout
récemment il se cachait
sortez pas je m'assure il tout juste
d'avoir un toit ce qui est peu par où
dormait en cash et on fait son vrai nom
n'est pas abdul c'est un nom d'emprunt
les premières fois qu'on l'a rencontré
il ne voulait pas montrer son visage à
la caméra c'est vraiment stressant c'est
une angoisse constante c'est pas qui
faire confiance ou s'afficher et c'est
vraiment compliqué et c'est très
fatigant à vivre
et pourtant l'histoire de cet homme
devenu clandestin avait tellement bien
commencé je suis parti aux états unis
pour être étudiant pour gagner en
reconnaissance mais surtout pour
découvrir la vie quoi arriver là bas moi
c'est c'était le rêve quoi
il voulait être libre pensée et agir par
lui-même parce qu abdul est né au
sénégal dans une famille aisée mais
conservatrice ce voyage d'étude devait
lui permettre de se soustraire à
l'emprise de son père mais le sentiment
de liberté sera de courte durée
[Musique]
montea voulais vraiment que je me marie
avec quelqu'un que moi même j'avais même
pas choisi vraiment maria lesquels
c'était déjà la folie quoi c'était genre
action pour moi
abdul est incapable de convaincre sa
famille d'annuler le mariage arrangé sa
vie commence à s'écrouler il dévoile
alors son plus grand secret et c'est
dans un coup d'énervement aussi que juin
oui que je t'ai objections prix très
très mal quoi et voulait plus parler
il disait qu'elle faisait plus partie de
la famille qui l'a pas mis au monde à un
homme comme moi il est donc renier
baning des siens et sans le sou il
enchaîne les boulots mais c'est
impossible
après l'école c'est ici mon apportera
que je pouvais plus et je me suis fait
éviter de là bas j'avais pas reçu
d'argent pour nos horaires non plus hein
il tombe dans l'itinérance il trotte du
travail pour un lit pour des repas abdul
cherche alors de l'aide de sa soeur qui
vit au canada
il se présente au poste frontière et
demande refuge
mais quelques mois plus tard le
gouvernement refuse de l'accueillir
comme réfugiés il doit quitter le pays
mais pas question pour lui de retourner
au sénégal c'est vraiment impossible
d'être gay dans le succès des sociétés
comme ça c'est pratiquement dangereux
même de l'être va parce que à plusieurs
occasions des gens se sont fait agresser
il disparaît alors du radar des
autorités canadiennes et il devient
clandestins
[Musique]
comme abdul ils sont des milliers à
disparaître tous les ans dans les
grandes villes du canada
[Musique]
c'est difficile de vivre sans papiers
impossible d'ouvrir un compte en banque
d'avoir un permis de conduire de louer
un appartement au de travailler
légalement les clandestins sont sans
droit est vulnérable et c'est comme ça
partout au pays
[Musique]
toronto la métropole canadienne héberge
des milliers de sans papiers et dans
cette maison ils peuvent trouver un
repas chaud de l'aide juridique et même
avoir accès à une clinique médicale
depuis des décennies francisco rico
martinez des 10es vie à la protection
des migrants des dons grave ils n'ont
pas de statut et il travaille dans la
construction dans différentes industries
dans des usines
ils font du ménage ils n'ont pas de
protection
francisco et son équipe sont débordés de
travail à cause de la pandémie
you know when i'm les appels n'ont pas
cessé ils ont explosé because we parce
qu'on est passé d'une organisation qui
aide les migrants dans les procédures
d'immigration à une banque alimentaire
pour les gens nous appelaient et disait
et donc on n'a rien à manger
francisco dénonce aussi la patte si des
gouvernements l'un des plus gros
problème c'est que le système n'est pas
équipé pour documenter combien il ya de
gens dans cette situation
combien sont ils pouvez vous me donner
un nombre
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait qui sont ils
c'est un vrai problème de le savoir
ah oui sont-ils 250000 à toronto
seulement il y aurait alors un demi
million de sans papiers au canada
peut-être même plus mais sans données
officielles impossible de savoir la
perception de façon images de milieux
finalisé on a souvent ancien juge à la
cour suprême du canada louise arbour a
aussi été représentante spéciale des
nations unies pour les migrations de
gens qui sont entrés au pays de façon
tout à fait régulière ou bien qu'ils
venaient d'un pays où on n'a pas besoin
du visage
les français les britanniques ou bien
qui sont tentés au canada avec un visa
de touriste ou invisibles d'éducation ça
arrive très souvent et qui sont eux
repartis ceux qui entrent au canada par
le chemin roxane ne sont d'ailleurs pas
des clandestins
ce sont des demandeurs d'asile qui
peuvent obtenir un permis de travail
temporaire
vous avez présentement 80 millions de
déplacés que ce soit pour des raisons
politiques quelle catastrophe naturelle
et tout ça n'est pas dans une bulle
vive donc qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
facile de dire on renvoie tout le monde
pensait que ça se fait ça ça se fait pas
denis coderre a déjà été ministre
canadien de l'immigration et maire de
montréal
il a même voulu créer une ville
sanctuaire pour les sans papiers les
gens quand ils voient en europe si par
exemple vient du moyen-orient dans leur
taille aps
ils vont retourner chez eux quand ils
traversent l'atlantique une brisure
ils se font une nouvelle vie y
retournons au pot c4 sandrine qui nous a
demandé de changer son nom et son
apparence pour protéger son identité
elle est venue au canada pour demander
l'asile politique je viens de l'afrique
subsaharienne
les présidents sont des dictateurs je
faisais un métier qui n'était pas en
phase avec le président actuel
à un moment j'étais menacé et puis il
fallait que je me sauve mais le canada a
rejeté sa demande de refuge malgré tout
elle décide de rester quand j'ai été
refusé
j'ai été tellement choquée j'ai dit je
ne peux pas retourner
peu importe les difficultés je peux
supporter retourner ce n'est pas sûr que
tu aura la vie sauve
tu feras de la prison c'est médiatisé et
tu es stigmatisés et j'ai décidé de
rester
je savais que je devenais illégale que
ma vie serait compliqué
croyez le ou non sandrine travaillent
dans l'industrie du tourisme depuis cinq
ans pour la même entreprise mais son
patron ignore qu'elle est une sans
papier
je pense que c'est un secret entre le
monsieur de l'agencé et je ne sais pas
comment ça se fâche la transaction et
justement c'est ce monde qu'ils ont fait
rouler l'économie canadienne pendant
toute la bande d'amis pendant que les
gens citoyens comme moi ont pu rester en
sécurité à la maison
l'étudiant fred bur il fait partie du
réseau militant solidarité sans
frontières tout comme sandrine
[Musique]
c'est ce groupe qui a organisé les
manifestations de sans-papiers cet été
on revendique la fin de tout déportation
qui aurait aucune déportation de
personnes de quiconque et du canada la
fin de toute détention pour les
personnes migrantes
mais avant l'activisme politique le plus
important pour les sans papiers c'est
d'avoir un gagne pain
ce que je fais c'est vraiment pour la
survie parce que je n'ai pas le choix
mais ce n'est pas de bon gré parce que
c'est humiliant c'est rabaissant c'est
frustrant je gagne moins que le salaire
minimum moins que le salaire minimum
c'est bien peu mais le prix de la
clandestinité peut être encore plus
élevé après la pause des gens sans
scrupules qui exploite les sans papiers
et qui mettent leur vie en danger
[Musique]
on l'appelle la capitale de la tomate
leamington une ville dans le sud ouest
de l'ontario
ici les étés sont longs et la terre
produit des fruits et des légumes qui
vont garnir les tablettes de nos
épiceries mais la beauté des lieux
cachent aussi des drames terribles
travail dans la région
aujourd'hui au moun yo c'était un
travailleur sans papiers arrivés au pays
comme touristes
sa mort a révélé au grand jour la
présence de centaines de clandestins
dans les fermes et leurs difficiles
conditions de travail
[Musique]
19 a révélé que des milliers de
travailleurs migrants sont victimes
d'exploitation dhabi de travail et
possiblement de trafic mais au canada
and luis alberto matin à une mission
bien particulière lutter contre le
trafic d'êtres humains le trafic des
personnes attirent l'attention de
l'opinion publique des médias des
gouvernements et des autorités
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'industrie du sexe
mais quand il est question de trafic de
travailleurs c'est quelque chose qui est
disparaît copine s'est littéralement
ignorés par une grande partie de la
société et des autorités
même par le gouvernement le problème
c'est que souvent les sans papiers
travaillent pour des réseaux bien
organisés qui échappent au contrôle des
autorités
un bon salaire ou la maison et de la
nourriture n'a rien donné
procès a été recruté par l'un de ces
raisons ce mexicain est aussi arrivé
avec un visa touriste et a rapidement
commencé à chercher du travail
il se souvient bien de sa première nuit
à leamington les romands sont intégrés
et personne ne nous attendait dans les
sous sols où on devrait dormir il avait
rien de ce qu'on nous avait promis pas
de nourriture et d'eau on était déjà six
personnes et et on attendait des
conditions insalubres et déplorable dit
il un cocktail explosif en temps de
pandémie
comment travailler tous à la même sphère
où on s'est infectée libre et passons à
des non pas des désagréments des
battages et tous contrôlés toujours
ensemble on utilisait la même salle de
bain on s'est tous infectés
on a commencé à contaminer tout le
village aussi tombe malade tout comme
son meilleur ami rejet du home union de
travailleurs clandestins morts à cause
des coûts vide mon ami avait 24 ans
c'est trop jeune
[Musique]
l'histoire de rosser est loin d'être une
exception et leamington n'est pas le
seul endroit au canada où des sans
papiers travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles ou parfois ils mettent leur
vie en danger
[Musique]
ils se sont un autre nom d'emprunt est
un commerçant mexicain qui vit
aujourd'hui à québec mais il a déjà
parcouru canada où travaillent
clandestinement dans la construction à
toronto
je travaillais dans la construction en
excavation et en démolition
c'était très difficile parce que c'était
moi qui était responsable de mesures est
l'endroit où l'on creusé la pelle
mécanique me passait tout près du corps
j'aurais pu facilement être frappés et
mourir on fait affaire avec des
sous-traitants ses jantes en bouche puis
il demande un bon salaire pour tes
services mais il garde la moitié de
taper les conditions liées à
l'exploitation bien sûr que ce soit en
faisant du travail domestique dans les
secteurs de l'agriculture de la
construction
et là on l'a vu dans le domaine de la
santé souvent des gens qui pensent qu'a
reprise agences qui sont pas toujours
très scrupuleuse et qui la travaillent
dans les situations souvent
d'exploitation de précarité
et jesús assure que ces agences de
placement profite de chaque dollar gagné
par les sans papiers il y a des gens
même des latinos qui te loue un espace
de deux mètres dans leur maison pour 300
dollars par mois et ils vont aussi de
trouver un emploi si tu leur donnes 100
$ par semaine pour que tu ne les
dénoncent pas ces personnes te demande
ton passeport
c'est la garantie que tu ne vas pas les
dénoncer tu dois leur donner des papiers
et après tu dois payer pour les
récupérer et quand la relation est
tendue
ou quand patrons refusent de payer ont
brandi des menaces alors il m'a dit
qu'est ce que tu vas faire tuer eux ni
légale sais tu que ce que tu fais est
illégal
je vais te le montrer voici mon
téléphone appelle la police si tu veux
je peux même appelé de servir
d'interprète
la police une menace ou une protection
c'est la question que se posent tous les
clandestins
[Musique]
au retour on vous parle d'enfants nés
ici au québec mais qui n'ont pas droit
aux soins de santé
[Musique]
toronto une ville en plein essor
une ville qui attire des immigrants d'un
peu partout dans le monde
[Musique]
c'est en banlieue qu'on retrouve césar
tatiana et le p tit henrique une famille
qui rêve de vivre en toute tranquillité
au canada enrique est arrivé dans les
bras de ses parents il y a cinq mois à
peine
césar est un ingénieur mexicain qui
travaillait pour une grande pétrolière
avant de venir au canada en 2018
on se disait où pourrions nous donner
une meilleure vie et nos enfants un
meilleur futur pour nous le seul lieu
qui nous venaient à l'esprit en amérique
c'était le canada les états-unis ont
mille bonnes choses mais ça n'a jamais
été un endroit de choix pour moi
personne ne croirait que professionnel
et un sans papiers avant de venir au
canada
il avait même fait le tour du monde
tatiana sa femme et une designer de mode
il a rencontré césar dans son pays en
colombie j'ai connu ces ardents un
mariage dans le mariage de mon meilleur
ami un mais didier
au début notre relation était à distance
mais finalement j'ai déménagé au mexique
où nous avons vécu ensemble avant de
venir au canada
on est venu chercher de l'information
sur les visas et les programmes pour
migrants on avait de l'argent et on
n'était pas pressé on est venu comme
touristes
pour voir si nous aimions le canada et
pour découvrir le pays
elbeuf c'est à ce moment là que nous
avons décidé de nous informer sur les
différentes universités
mais au début 2019
leur vie bascule j'ai connu une femme
qui m'a offert une meilleure opportunité
que celles d'étudier deux ans bon je
croyais que c'était une meilleure
opportunité
c'est là que notre calvaire a commencé
césar a connu une avocate qui lui a
offert de faire tous les papiers je me
suis retrouvé dans une toile de
mensonges de fausses promesses
je me suis retrouvé sans mon passeport
son passeport est entre les mains de
cette fameuse avocate à qu'il a versé
beaucoup d'argent elle n'était pas une
avocate nie une consultante
d'immigration ni rien lorsqu'il découvre
larnack il est trop tard
tatiana est enceinte et leurs économies
ont fondu
[Musique]
quand j'ai su que j'allais devenir papa
notre vie est devenu très critique
ce moment devrait toujours être heureux
mais ma femme et moi on n'a pas pu
profiter de notre grossesse
et ça ne s'arrête pas là pour se loger
pour payer les visites à l'hôpital
tatiana et césar accepte à contrecoeur
de travailler illégalement pour la
fausse avocate pas là pour moi ça a été
très difficile parce que nous
travaillons pour elle le travail était
dur
césar dans la construction et moi je
faisais du ménage même si j'étais
enceinte
on n'avait pas d'autre option parce
qu'on était des illégaux
comme si c'était pas assez n'obtiennent
rick est né en mai dernier très malade
on doit l'opérer à coeur ouvert après
plusieurs examens
on nous a dit qu'il avait une
malformation cardiaque congénitale
c'est comme un trou à l'intérieur du
coeur enrique doit se battre pour vivre
il est hospitalisé pendant des mois sous
le regard de sa mère
ces arts lui ne peut pas se permettre de
manquer une seule journée de travail
j'ai mis mes propres besoins de côté je
dois remplir les promesses que j'ai fait
à ma femme et à mon bébé
la maladie du petit gris qui force
encore aujourd'hui césar a travaillé
pour la course avocat qui contrôle toute
sa vie mel est loin d'être la seule qui
profitent des sans papiers non non non
je ne suis qu'un cas sur des milliers de
cas et incluant des situations bien
pires je connais beaucoup de gens qui se
font des millions en louant des
appartements aux migrants sans papiers
césar et tatiana ont dénoncé la femme
qui les a bernés aux policiers une
enquête est en cours
je n'ai jamais pensé que je quitterais
un pays du tiers-monde où je vivais une
bonne vie pour un pays développé où je
vivrai une vie comme on voit dans les
films d'horreur
mon plus grand rêve c'est d'être ici
légalement de travailler dans ce que
j'aime
il ne plus faire de ménage faire ce que
j'aime et voir ma famille et comment
vois tu l'avenir
je ne sais pas
enrique est maintenant sorti de
l'hôpital mais au cours des prochaines
années
il aura besoin de soins spécialisés ses
parents ne veulent donc pas quitter le
pays si la vie de clandestin qui se
poursuit
césar doit continuer de travailler sans
travail sa famille n'aura rien à manger
mais il n'est pas au bout de ses peines
si j'ai un accident au travail
c'est la pire chose qui pourrait nous
arriver
partout au canada les ambulances les
urgences les hôpitaux les médecins ne
sont pas accessibles aux sans papiers
ils n'ont pas accès à la santé publique
gratuite comme les autres
tatiana par exemple a dû payer pour ces
suivis de grossesse mais tous les sans
papiers ne peuvent pas se permettre
heureusement il ya des protecteurs qui
leur viennent en aide comme dans cette
clinique de montréal
autour de 2009 moi j'ai commencé à avoir
des demandes de personnes migrantes à
statut précaire que c'était des gens qui
avaient des emplois qui étaient tombés
sur un chantier de construction qui
s'était cassé un bras fait clos nous on
savait plus quoi faire avec ces gens là
médecins du monde offrent des services
ou migrants qui n'ont pas accès au
système de santé dont des sans papiers
il ya des personnes la dent qui se cache
la plus portent les gens qui nous ont
cure qui viennent nous voir vont
attendre vraiment longtemps qu'ils
auront pas le choix de venir consulter
quand ils viennent ils ont par du
système d'immigration uniquement dans
cette clinique
médecins du monde est d'environ mille
personnes par année et on a des belles
histoires de gens qu'on a suivi pendant
plusieurs années
qui maintenant ont un statut qui
maintenant aux axes et puis qui nous
remercient des thés d'avoir été le mais
la clinique ne peut pas remplacer le
système de santé
mais on arrive au bout de ce qu'on est
capable de faire quand les gens arrivent
ici avec des cancers avec des maladies
chroniques
on fait ce qu'on peut mais on n'arrive
pas on pourra jamais répondre à la
demande faudrait qu'il y aura un
accident système
un accès pour tous c'est le rêve de ses
protecteurs et des clandestins aussi
mais le système de santé et provinciales
et les choses sont différentes d'un
endroit à l'autre de petits américains
parce qu'il est un citoyen canadien a
été pris en charge par le système de
santé en ontario
il semble même si ses parents sont des
clandestins mais s'ils vivaient au
québec
les choses seraient différentes il ya
plein de personnes qui sont pas au
courant dès maintenant et même des
infirmières qui nous disaient les bébés
qui naissent au québec c'est des
citoyens canadiens donc ils ont accès à
la carte ram qu nom des citoyens
canadiens des bébés qui naissent ici
si leurs parents ont pas accès à la
carte tram q le bébé est citoyen
canadien mais n'auront pas accès à la
carte ramq non plus céder des citoyens
canadiens de deuxième vingt alors les
bébés n'ont pas de service parce que les
parents n'ont pas de carte d'assurance
maladie
voici des factures de près de 20 mille
dollars reçus par les parents d'un bébé
malade né au québec l'hiver dernier et
sont ici ils vivent ici vont jamais
connu aucun autre pays qu ici
il n'y a pas que des organismes comme
médecins du monde qui dénonce cette
situation
en 2018 le protecteur du citoyen du
québec demandé que tous les enfants ni
au pays même sur des clandestins et
accès gratuitement au système de santé
le gouvernement avait alors dit qu'il
étudiait la question considérant qu'il
s'agit d'un phénomène récent est
difficile à chiffrer
le ministère a récemment mandaté un
comité de travail interministériel
coordonné par la ramq eu pour documenter
le phénomène un phénomène récent du
temps des pourtant il y a 20 ans on
assuré que le sujet était clos
cette nouvelle n de l'article de loi du
gouvernement de l'époque où françois
legault et ministre a fait adopter une
loi pour donner un accès gratuit à la
santé à tous les enfants nés ici et
pourtant rien n'a changé jusqu'à
maintenant donc la ramq finalement elle
s'est dit tiens on va faire notre
règlement interne
ils appliquent pas la décision du
législateur ce qui connaît un petit peu
grave parce que démocratie devraient
suivre les élus et pas suivre ce que et
trans tout le temps une demande
d'actions collectives qu'on fait le
gouvernement a été déposée l'été dernier
dans ce dossier et le gouvernement a
répondu la même chose qu'il ya vingt ans
il dit avoir l'intention d'élargir la
couverture médicale aux enfants nés au
québec de parents ayant un statut
d'immigration prêtèrent bien sûr les
bébés clandestins bénéficierait d'une
telle mesure
en attendant des enfants se font
toujours refusé des soins de santé sans
frais au québec
[Musique]
dans un instant on vous raconte comment
ça se passe à la prison du sans papiers
là bas on est tous traités comme comme
des détenus des prisonniers
il n'y a pas de différence
[Musique]
voici le centre de surveillance de
l'immigration à laval qui frappe en
premier c'est vrai qu'ils sont les
barbelés les fenêtres condamnées
ça me redonne tout de suite l'image de
l'intérieur comme pour mon sens vraiment
pas mal séparée du monde quoi
cet endroit fait peur aux sans papiers
qui vivent clandestinement pays
là bas on est tous traités comme comme
des détenus des prisonniers
il n'y a pas de différence il y a trois
centres comme celui ci au canada c'est
là que les clandestins séjourne avant
d'être déportés et les heures fixes pour
se lever à 5h30 à ce genre doit manger
tiens employés le temps bien déterminée
déjà si besoin d'aidé rendez vous en
ville
par exemple on a besoin de voir des
agents d'immigration
[Musique]
abdul connais bien ce centre il y a vécu
plusieurs semaines et pour en sortir il
a même fait une grève de la faim il a de
bien mauvais souvenir de l'endroit et il
y en a aussi des occasions où on se
retrouve pratiquement ligoté de partout
par exemple qu'on devait aller à
l'hôpital on est et ligoté deux des
pieds et des mains aussi et c'est
vraiment aussi une expérience humiliante
fait dire parce qu'on traverse tout
l'hôpital remplie de monde avec toutes
ces chaînes autour ce sens vraiment
comme un danger pour te ment ces centres
sont gérés par l' agence des services
frontaliers du canada
mais ceux qui s'occupent des détenus
sont des agents de sécurité privés
selon cette offre d'emploi ils sont
payés 20 $ de l'heure al embauche
ils doivent avoir un secondaire 5 ou une
expérience équivalente
ils sont autour de 15 va et puis s'ils
font des rondes
j'ai eu plein de reprise à faire des
plaintes par rapport aux autres
ce recours aux compagnies privées a déjà
été critiquée et pas seulement par les
sans papiers parce que ces gardiens
s'occupe de personnes qui sont souvent
détresse psychologique
il ya sept ans une sans-papiers s'est
enlevé la vie dans l'un de ses centres à
vancouver la veille de sa déportation à
la suite d'une enquête
une coroner a critiqué le recours à des
agents de sécurité privés
les gardes de sécurité privés n'était
pas aussi bien formés que les employés
de l'agencé des services frontaliers du
canada et il y avait un taux de
roulement élevé du personnel
probablement en raison des bas salaires
il n'avait été formé que pour mettre des
chaînes aux pieds menottés et donner les
premiers soins de base
aujourd'hui l' agence des services
frontaliers assure que ses gardiens
reçoivent les formations appropriées
le recours au privé représente un
meilleur rapport qualité prix pour le
gouvernement du canada a dit on abdul ne
veut pas être enfermé nouveau dans ce
centre mais il sait bien qu'on peut le
forcer à revenir à tout moment pour le
déporter
[Musique]
dans la rue ce sont les sirènes les
gyrophares et les uniformes qui effraie
les clandestins tous les jours je fais
attention
tous les jours je sais que ça peut
arriver d'un moment à l'autre
je ne suis pas à l'abri du moment où je
fais un faux pas c'est fini les
personnes sans papiers ont peur de la
police et ils ont pas avec raison parce
qu'ils savent qu'il ya un risque de
détention qui a un risque de déportation
alors qu'ils se rendent au travail alors
qu'ils amènent leurs enfants à l'école
dans la vie de tous les jours le risque
de se retrouver dans les mailles de
l'agent services frontaliers
ça passe par les policiers dans la
majorité des cas le sociologue david
moffett s'intéresse de près aux
interactions entre les policiers
municipaux et les sans papiers des
données que j'ai obtenu d'accès à
l'information nous montre que 10000 fois
par année à travers le pays
des policiers de différents corps de
police donc des policiers municipaux
vont téléphoner à leurs collègues pour
vérifier du fer informations sur des
personnes qu'ils ont devant elles sapent
eux de vérifier si un mandat d'arrêt
pour cette personne là mais dans la
majorité des cas c'est pour déterminer
le statut d'immigration d'une personne
ces informations de 2019 montre qu'en
comparaison avec leurs collègues du pays
c'est la police de montréal qui remporte
le palmarès des contacts avec
l'immigration canadienne
en moyenne les policiers de montréal
appelé l' agence des services
frontaliers dix fois par jour
des contacts qu'on est incapable
d'exécuter vos tickets ce qui amène ça
c'est que tout le monde peut appliquer
pratiquement n'importe quel policier sur
la route + téléphonie pour faire donc
pour retracer tout ça ça devient
difficile
la police de montréal avoue qu'il y a eu
certains dérapages dans le passé c'est
là ce n'est pas le mandat des policiers
municipaux d'appliquer la loi sur
l'immigration
si le policier demande une personne
quelle est votre statut au canada dans
le but de la dénoncer son nom c'est pas
dans le travail donc ça à ce moment là
je vous dirai ça ce n'est pas acceptable
la police a toutefois l'obligation
d'exécuter les mandats d'arrestation il
selon le bureau du vérificateur général
du canada
35000 sans papiers sont recherchés et
près de 3000 d'entre eux ont un passé
criminel
mais la grande majorité des clandestins
ne sont pas des criminels et les
autorités aimeraient bien tissé des
liens de confiance avec eux on veut que
les personnes qui sera interpellé soient
en sécurité
parfois on a des victimes d'actes
criminels qui ont peur d'aller vers le
service de police où on a des témoins
d'actes criminels ou si rose année
filato est responsable de la sécurité
publique à la ville de montréal
à son avis l'une des solutions pour se
rapprocher des 50000 sans papiers qui
vivent dans la métropole québécoise
pourrait être la création d'une carte
d'identité municipal on peut penser aux
modèles de new york par exemple
oui une carte universel pour l'ensemble
des citoyens et des citoyennes qui
devient une façon de signifier
officiellement donc ça serait une carte
universel justement qui ferait en sorte
que un policier une policière ne
remettrait pas en question le statut de
la personne le statut migratoire donc on
ne poserait pas cette question là et on
appellerait pas l' agence de services
frontaliers
cette solution viendrait s'ajouter à une
décision prise par la police il ne faut
pas laissée au bon vouloir de chaque
policier de contact et l'immigration
un policier peu importe où sur le
territoire va devoir appeler un endroit
central ou spvm
et si une personne qui va faire les
veilles des validations des
vérifications
lestrem travaille actuellement sur un
projet de guichet donc de trouver une
façon pour que les policiers n'appellent
pas directement l'agent ce n'est pas par
je vais je l'expliqué simplement par un
filtre donc pour analyser au cas par cas
est ce que c'est un corps où on doit
appeler
ces mesures devront cependant faire
leurs preuves après des années de
méfiance
il faudra probablement du temps pour
bâtir des ponts entre les autorités les
sans papiers on n'est pas sans papiers
parce qu'on est criminel on n'est pas
sans papiers parce qu'on est des
méchants de la société il ya des
circonstances qui amène les gens à être
sans papiers c'est comme quelqu'un qui
est malade on n'est pas malade parce
qu'on veut
[Musique]
le sujet des clandestins n'est pas
simple pour beaucoup de canadiens tout
comme pour le gouvernement
ceux qui n'ont pas l'autorisation d'être
ici doivent partir mais d'autres parlent
plutôt de trouver des solutions
une amnistie par exemple moi je pense
que ce qu'on doit préconiser à ce moment
là ces données est réalisée et ça ça
veut dire avant de les inviter à sortir
de l'ombre et non les prêts à vous
donner l'opportunité d'entrer dans une
société régulière de ne plus être des
sans papiers d'avoir des papiers
régulariser la situation
et c'est une politique tout à fait
courant dans la plupart des pays
européens où on régularise les gens qui
sont là mais doit-on régulariser tous
les sans papiers les gens qui font face
à des accusations criminelles
condamnation c'est tout à fait alors
bonjour à tous
pour l'ex-ministre de l'immigration qui
comme maire a voulu faire de montréal
une ville sanctuaire chaque cas est
unique
autant je peux pas être en accord avec
une amnistie générale
autant on doit s'assurer que ce que
c'est du cas par cas
puis d'inventer déportation si quelques
infos et le système être canadien ces
points droite plus village
[Musique]
quoi qu'il en soit les centaines de
milliers de clandestins au canada rêve
seulement de vivre comme les autres
[Musique]
où
oh
ici
[Musique]
j'espère que le reportage de ce soir
vous a touché au nom de toute l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là je vous
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]
on